[Music]  actress lindsay lohan is mounting a  comeback and this morning she appeared  on the today show it was a fascinating  interview take a look  over the last several years lindsay  lohan has certainly faced her troubles  most of them self-inflicted this week  she will try to mount a comeback when  she hosts saturday night live we sat  down with her for an exclusive interview  on tuesday that you're going to see in  its entirety tomorrow i began by asking  her the question on everyone's mind  let's start on common ground okay you  and the president agree that we cannot  walk away from our relationship with  pakistan at this moment in time when you  look at pakistan do you see a true ally  i don't  not not really i've i don't i wouldn't  like to i don't want to go there  again we will have our full exclusive  interview with lindsay lohan tomorrow  right here  [Applause]